[Musique]
que témoignage je t'aime aussi à
franchir mais d'une manière à coup dans
la gueule non mais je te jure un
franchement continue à tomber quand il a
livré je m'étais fait monter dans le car
avec mon père est tout à fait mais je te
nomme vraiment j'ai eu la larme à l'oeil
non mais sans déconner mais je sais ça
émouvant moi aussi je me disais
peut-être qu'elle lorgnait marais voir
aussi de quoi bein bakkour comme ça
l'autoroute du succès a pour l'instant
fait ta chronique
on commence à avoir très classe ce soir
c'est très très classe non moi oui je
sais pas ce que vous arrivez au soir
vous touchez shin bet
c'est tout mou ces monstres rire
[Rires]
cyril alors il ya beaucoup de dossiers
ce soir et on arrive en fin de saison
c'est là où commencer à décider si vous
renouveler ou pas les gens et je prends
des risques puisque toute la chronique
et sur votre pomme ce soir paraît bien
sûr c'est une formation si susi je peux
recevoir en recommander à mon avis dans
les 24 heures
c'est long commence comme chaque semaine
avec la gazette de off c'est tout ce qui
se passe pendant les pubs pendant les
magnétos la 4c moderne ça reste c'est la
gazette ces mots guérissent murs des
revirements des amas on y va c'est parti
c'est la gazette san siro
lors comment cyril qui arrive sur le
plateau quelques secondes avant
l'antenne avec une sobriété mais une
sobriété
[Musique]
oh
on
continue avec daniel et cette question
que tout le monde se pose y at il
quelqu'un pour sauver sa culotte
son sourire
moi vraiment de me dire bouffe
est décidément quand cyril tu as une
bonne il la répète à tout le monde et je
voulais dit la semaine dernière à tout
le plateau je crois que nous aurons à
faire un contrebandier
écoutez ça contrebande et en dehors des
questions cet accoutrement dino d'airgas
appartement qui met définitivement fin
le roi de la répartie et le prouve
chaque jour et des salades humanime eu
qui sort
[Musique]
les pères proches et vous voulez maigrir
je vous comprends laissez vous tenter
par le régime hanouna j'ai mangé que
détonnant series avec moi tu attends et
mes couilles
et auteur been avec papa au cibona
interviewer à l'antenne que pendant les
pubs ont regardé si on me demande de
bouffer si on me demande de bouffer la
reine elizabeth ii
[Applaudissements]
très bonne question
la question dont justement qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce qu'on ferait pour le jubilé
taton français
[Applaudissements]
j'adore les framboises
maintenant je pense qu'elle voue corps
démembré en parlant de frambois des
fruits à paul mirabel dans le public
soit derrière vous regardez au sérieux
merci merci paul mirabel merci l'état
qu'est-ce qu'il a d'autres moi c'est
jean-jacques ananas
sinon je vais pas m'abaisser à l'effet
testicules alors cyril la semaine
dernière rappelez vous on assistait un
très gros clash entre deux villes gilles
verdez et gilles favard à nice ils
tentent l'incroyable mais sur ce plateau
il ya un petit sheitan ce sheitan il est
à côté de moi au lieu de calmer les
choses qu'est ce qu'il fait lui il
arrive et leurs graines il en aimait son
petit piment et jetant des oeufs et au
calme toi
si l'on compare les données oui
absolument abondé abbas a oui oui oui si
elle parlait de malhonnête pêche vous
avez regardé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ça va
alors y'a pas taper les pompes sur des
projets d'accords soit dit gervais il va
tout énervé fois tapas but est taillée
dans un casino de bâle ministre
[Applaudissements]
l'écho
s'il te plaît
déjà pas mort et spa poli mois
non
l'attak pratiquants franchement c'est
vrai ça dort et sceptique la cascade est
est bien assez magnifique ben justement
ce magnéto il a servi grâce à une caméra
qui est fixé sur vous n'en savez qu'on
laisse une caméra que sur vous pour voir
ce que vous faites pendant les pubs et
bien il ya aussi des sujets sérieux dans
l'émission à la fin et pendant les
sujets sérieux que fait cyril hanouna à
votre avis est-ce qu'il suit les débats
où est ce qu'ils essaient à tout prix de
remplir ses orifices
la réponse aux les matches
[Musique]
série
d'aidés que c'est vrai que je vous dirai
peut-être mais quand on serait être
hargneux
je rappelle 1 kg de muscles brûlent par
jour sans bouger 30 calories qu'une bête
mais ce qu'il faut dans un régime
je pense qu il fait de l'exercice le
grinch déjà je fais quatre heures par
jour de sport ch un manchot entre eux
ils vous faites de l'exercice en
mouillant la chemise c'est à dire que
vous faites tous les monstres heures et
je
payais mes amis je te lis jeu monstrueux
le pancréas fait l'insuline mais c'est
le foie qui réguler la glycémie
jeu monstrueux
bien sûr le foie a bien sûr c'est que
vous voyez bien effectivement que ça
heurte
moyens y compris des buts
ça choquait d'ailleurs beaucoup de gens
ya des cultures minoritaires
détermination et je viendrai
et
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
le truc c'est qu'il me regarde et je
faisais un deux trois rennais vient
jouer télérama
ya d'autres choses qui arrivent voilà
c'est tout pour moi attendaient sicile
si l'on donne trop après il faut créer
le manque